اسبوع الرابع للاشتباكات في السودان
ودعواتنا لمحادثات جديه
اكثر من عشرين قتيلا في الهند بغرق قارب
سياحي
السجن لحراس ادخلها هواتف لسجناء من داعش
في العراق
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
الصراف في السودان دخل اسبوعه الرابع ولا
هدوء او هدنه على الارض حاليا مصادر
العربيه افادت بتجدد الاشتباكات بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في عدد من
النقاط بالعاصمه الخرطومه وتركزت في احياء
مدينه الخرطوم بحري اما على صعيد مفاوضات
التهدئه في جده فحتى السعوديه والولايات
المتحده طرفي النزاع على الانخراط بجديه
في المحادثات وذلك لتحقيق وقف فعال قصير
المدى لاطلاق النار والعمل على تسهيل وصول
المساعدات الانسانيه ووضع جدول زمني
لمفاوضات موسعه للوصول لوقف دائم
للاشتباكات
حادث ماساوي شهدته الهند حيث قضى 22 شخصا
على الاقل في غرق قارب سياحي من طابقين في
ولايه كيرا الى جنوب البلاد وفقا للسلطات
المحليه الشرطه قالت ان 30 شخصا كانوا على
متن القارب السياحي قبل ان يغرق ويؤدي الى
وفاه خمسه عشر بل 15 امراه وسبعه رجال وان
الفرق الانقاذ تواصل عمليات البحث عن
اخرين لكن يتوقع ان يكون معظمهم قد فارق
الحياه فيما ذكرت احدى الصحف المحليه
الهنديه ان من بين الوفيات احد عشر شخصا
من عائله واحده بينهم ثلاثه اطفال
[موسيقى]
من الهند الى العراق حيث اصدرت محكمه
الجنايات حكما بالسجن عشر سنوات على اربعه
حراس لادخالهم هواتف وشرائح اتصال للنزلاء
المحكومين من تنظيم داعش لقاء المبالغ
ماليه وكانت السلطات العراقيه قد اعلنت في
ابره الماضي عن كشف شبكه داعش تعمل داخل
السجن قامت بتجنيد مدنينا ونصبت قاده
وامراء لاعاده هيكله التنظيم تمهيدا
لتنفيذ مخطط ارهابي كبير داخل العراق
وخرجه وفقا للسلطات القضائيه العراقيه وهو
ما اعترف به المدنون خلال التحقيق معهم
في المكسيك قالت صحيفه البريطانيه ان
اربعه من ابناء زعيم المخدرات المكسيكيه
الشابو نشر ورساله ينفون فيها اي دور لهم
في شبكه تجاره المخدرات الخاصه بوالدهم
مضيفين انهم وقعوا ضحايا حمله تضليل وانهم
لم يسيطروا على اعمال والدهم
وانكر وايضا انهم جزء من شبكه التهرب
وتنشر كميات ضخمه من المخدرات داخل
الولايات المتحده والتي كانت قد اتهمت
الرجال الاربعه بانهم جزء من مجموعه
مسؤوله عن تهريب المواد المخدره الى
امريكا
خبرنا الاخير من الصين التي شهدت عوده
مركبه فضاء تجريبيه غامضه الى الارض بعد
بقائها في الفضاء لمده 276 يوما وبحسب ما
ذكرت وسائل الاعلام الصينيه الرسميه فانها
كانت بمهمه تاريخيه لاختبار تقنيات قابله
لاعاده الاستخدام والتي ستوفر الطريق
ملائمه وغير مكلفه للمهام الفضائيه في
المستقبل المصادر الصينيه اضافت ان
المركبه غير الماهوله عادت كما هو مقرر
لها الى مركز جيو تشيوان لاطلاق الاقمار
الاصطناعيه في الصين
[موسيقى]